if countries were people
the relationship between china america
and taiwan
would be a love triangle like no other
china claims taiwan as its own but with
america's support
taiwan has been able to fend off the
mainland's advances
[Applause]
to taiwan we are an independent country
we have
the military and and we have elections
but as china becomes stronger it's also
becoming more impatient
if china tries to take taiwan by force
it could lead to war with america these
are two
nuclear-armed countries it's kind of an
unimaginable horror
but it is a risk and you know
maybe sooner than we think
taiwan is located just 100 miles off the
chinese coast
but it's not just the taiwan strait that
separates them
the island's official status is a hotly
contested
issue for people in taiwan and for most
of the world
taiwan is an independent country
but as far as the chinese government is
concerned taiwan is a renegade
province which must be reunified
with china for the past 70 years
the threat of american military
intervention has ensured that didn't
happen
there has been a long-standing
agreement china has claimed that the
united states is destabilizing peace in
the taiwan strait
the expectation is that america is at a
minimum
the security guarantor that if china
invaded
they should expect the us seventh fleet
to turn up very soon and that could be a
war
this precarious standoff is a
consequence of the unique role
taiwan has played in china's divided
history
[Music]
at the end of the second world war the
defeated japanese
who had occupied taiwan for 50 years
were forced to give up control
taiwan was handed back to the republic
of china
then a military dictatorship led by
chiang kai-shek's
chinese nationalist party but it was a
short-lived union
within months china's civil war which
had been fought intermittently since
ignited once more
by 1949 mao's red army had swept to
victory
deposing chiang kai-shek's military
dictatorship
and forcing the former leader and around
1.2 million of his anti-communist
supporters
to retreat to taiwan to the kind of
grand gentry and aristocracy of mainland
china
taiwan was not somewhere they respected
or liked at all it is
a backwater and yet because the
nationalist regime
under chiang kai-shek had to go
somewhere the last place that they could
go to
was taiwan mao was preparing to invade
taiwan
and crush the deposed leader once and
for all
[Music]
but then war broke out on the korean
peninsula
the communists had finally launched
their undeclared
all-out war of conquest with the pacific
now the new front in the fight against
communism america formed an alliance
with chiang kai-shek's regime
and forced mao to give up his plans for
a taiwan takeover
from formosa chong carries on his long
and valiant effort to defeat the forces
of communism
emboldened by america's support chiang
kai-shek declared taiwan as
the one true republic of china and vowed
to return to re-take the mainland
this is a really unusual situation
everyone on both sides agreed
that there was only one country called
china they just disagreed
what it was was it a right-wing country
called the republic of china
or a communist country called the
people's republic of china
although no longer fighting face to face
mao and chiang kai-shek were now in a
battle for
international recognition and legitimacy
initially chiang kai-shek's government
held china's seat on the u.n security
council
and was recognized by many western
countries as the only chinese government
[Applause]
[Music]
our great socialist fatherland is in a
bright and splendid morning
but as mao's china became of increasing
strategic importance to america during
the u.s
soviet cold war chiang kai-shek's
influence diminished
in 1971 america allowed a u.n resolution
to recognize
mao's people's republic as the one and
only china
and after years of secret talks in 1979
washington shifted diplomatic
recognition from taiwan's capital
taipei to beijing
the mainland would not allow two chinas
or one china and one taiwan they
insisted on having
one china the one china principle became
a bedrock of the communist regime
and most of the world no longer
recognized chiang kai-shek's government
unofficially however there was still
strong sympathy in the west for taiwan
not least from its ex-partner america
but it was no longer quite so outspoken
about its affection
the taiwan's relations act is both the
strongest promise that america
still makes to taiwan but also it falls
a long way short
of a full defense treaty and a full
promise
that america will definitely protect
taiwan no matter what
america's lack of commitment led taiwan
to find another way to stand on its own
two feet
through economic growth
taiwan's small agricultural economy had
already undergone
rapid industrialization in the 1980s its
exports boomed
as economic growth surged on both sides
of the taiwan strait
taiwan and china let down their barriers
initially taiwanese businesses set up
factories on the mainland
reaping huge rewards but as china's
economy began to catch up
leaders in beijing realized they'd found
one way to break down
taiwan's resistance to merging with the
mainland
it was the start of a long-term policy
to woo
taiwan through economic influence
the chinese government saw that this is
a phenomenally
useful opportunity to make the two
economy
so integrated that it will be
economically
suicidal for any government in taiwan
to try to come into a kind of
confrontation
with china which will therefore require
the government in taiwan to accept some
form of unification
with china
and so the chinese communist party
suddenly started to drop its kind of
implacable hostility to everything to do
with taiwan
you saw direct flights direct ferries
direct shipping
and a huge interconnection
but while economic ties tightened
cultural divisions between taiwan and
the mainland deepened
[Music]
political reforms in the 1980s led to
the birth of the opposition party
the democratic progressive party or dpp
who supported an independent taiwan just
two years later
progressive lee or mr democracy as he
would come to be called
became the island's first taiwanese-born
leader
national assembly elections in 1991 were
hailed as taiwan's first true democratic
elections
within a decade taiwan became
a full-blown true democracy
and people in taiwan are extremely proud
of
their democracy and that is something
which
help to define their sense of identity
[Music]
alongside democratization came a growing
desire for a separate identity
much to the dismay of leaders in beijing
in 1996 china used its military might to
threaten taiwan
[Music]
and so famously in 1996 they launched
these missile tests
off the coast of taiwan to try and
frighten the taiwanese people into not
voting
for lee donghue who was in their view
too much of a kind of pro-taiwanese
figure i think
it is a very bad mistake on their part
to put the
impact area so near to taiwan i deplore
that decision on their part
america responded with the biggest
display of military might in asia since
the vietnam war
this made china aware of how difficult
it would be to stop
american forces assisting taiwan
but china's attempts to meddle in
taiwanese affairs continued
despite claims it wanted a peaceful
reunification with taiwan
in 2005 china passed an anti-secession
law
authorizing the use of force should
taiwan formally declare independence
that was meant to kind of intimidate the
taiwanese people
but it does intimidate some people but
it also makes the idea of unification
with china all the more unattractive and
just kind of plain weird to younger
taiwanese people
with the younger generation increasingly
alienated from china
more recent attempts by taiwan's
government even to just forge closer
economic ties have met with opposition
in 2014 the sunflower movement occupied
parliament to protest against a free
trade deal with china
well for most people in taiwan
they think that china has every right to
have a one china principle
it just cannot include us and they
simply will not accept
the prospect of being part of a
very hard authoritarian leninist
political system whatever the economic
benefits
so up to this point the chinese approach
of
using economic integration to achieve
political unification
has failed since the 1990s a growing
proportion of people in taiwan see
themselves as taiwanese
rather than chinese these views helped
sai yin won
the pro-independence dpp candidate win
election in 2016
as president of taiwan
and just three years later events 440
miles
southwest would create even more support
for taiwanese independence
in 2019 hundreds of thousands of people
took to the streets of hong kong and
battled with police
to protest against chinese encroachments
on hong kong's freedoms
for many in taiwan including the
president it was a stark
warning
the more that china shows its teeth and
shows that it's not willing to tolerate
even a semi-democracy in a place like
hong kong
the more that the taiwanese people think
what kind of promise of autonomy
makes any sense for us
[Music]
as voluntary unification looks
increasingly remote
china has only its military might to
fall back on
in 2020 the chinese government released
a propaganda video
that appeared to show the chinese armed
forces conducting
attacks on the u.s military base in guam
it was a sign that china is considering
the use of force
far afield in order to prevent america
coming to taiwan's aid
is america still able to deter china
does
the people's liberation army fear that
it would lose a war
and that america would turn up to defend
taiwan
that's now in real doubt these are two
nuclear-armed countries it's kind of an
unimaginable horror
it should be impossible to imagine this
not
ending peacefully but it is also
impossible to imagine this chinese
government
allowing taiwan to drift away
i'm david rennie beijing purity for the
economist to read our recent briefing
on the dangers facing taiwan and the
rest of our coverage of taiwan and china
click the link and thank you for
watching
you